I'm going to show you how to connect
with anyone, even if it feels like you
have nothing in common. I'm talking
about when you're having a conversation
with a coworker and you're both stuck
talking about the weather, when you're
meeting somebody new and thinking,
"We're just too different." Or when
you're at an event that's full of people
and you feel like you don't belong in
[music] any of the conversations. As
long as you follow this exact framework
that I'm about to share with you in this
video, you'll never sit across from
someone and think, "We've got nothing in
common." ever again. This one framework
is a big part of how I've been able to
connect with 95% of people that I've met
as a communication coach and a global
keynote speaker. But before I teach it
to you, I need to address the biggest
mistake I see people make when they're
trying to find common ground. I'll draw
it out for you. Imagine this is you,
slightly taller and slightly better
looking. And this is the person that you
are talking to, them, the other person.
You're both in the small talk phase and
you secretly both are doing the exact
same thing. You're both hunting for
something that you have in common. The
other person mentions
fishing. And the moment they mention
fishing, you immediately think to
yourself, "I've got zero interest in
that. I hate fishing." So instead of
digging into it, you change the
conversation to something that you care
about. And here, you go, "Nice. I'm
really into rock climbing."
And now the other person's thinking to
themselves, "Rock climbing? What am I, a
monkey? No, it's not for me." And now
you both have arrived at the exact same
conclusion. We both have nothing in
common. That's how 90% of conversations
go. They're surface level, there's no
depth, and it happens because you're
trying to find common ground in a
straight line, in a linear way. I like
this, you don't like this, yes, we've
got nothing in common. And when someone
says they like fishing, there's more to
it than just the fishing component.
Maybe they like being out in the ocean.
Maybe they find it peaceful. Maybe they
enjoy nature. Maybe it's because they
love being self-sufficient and catching
their own food. There are so many other
things is fishing can represent for the
other person. And that right there lies
the secret in being able to find
something in common with every single
person you connect with. The framework,
it's called match.
That's exactly what you're doing. You're
trying to find a match between their
world and your world. Let's set a scene
first of all to work with
>> [music]
>> because this happens to everybody. So,
you're at work and there's this
colleague of yours that you've worked
with together for the last 3 years, but
you know literally nothing about them
because you're afraid that you have
nothing in common with them. I want you
to imagine for a second that you invited
them out for lunch and you said, "Hey,
we've been working together for the last
3 years. Let's have lunch together. I'm
buying." And now you're both at lunch
and you've got your sandwich and they've
got their pasta. And normally at this
point you'd be freaking out, but freak
out no more because you're about to
learn the match framework because it's
going to help you find the things you
have in common with people so you can
ignite connection. So, what's M?
Let's get into it. M stands for make
an offer.
Before you ask a single question, you
share something about you first. Like
this. Hey, I'm so glad we're finally
having lunch together. You know, one of
the reasons why I left my previous job
is because I really believe in what we
do here. You know, helping people find
their voice and share their gifts and
shine their light into the world. It
really gives me a lot of fulfillment.
You see, now that's an offer. It's
small, but it does two things. It lowers
their guard because you went first and
it shows them the depth that you're
inviting. You go shallow, they're going
to go shallow. You go deeper and trust
me, they'll go deeper. Think of it like
tennis. You can't have a rally until
someone actually serves the damn ball.
Making an offer is you serving first. It
gives them something to swing at. So,
that's M. You go first. Now, what comes
next, Vin? It's okay, don't rush me. I'm
getting to it. The next one is A which
stands for ask across
high
yielding areas.
Here's where most people run dry. They
ask, "So, what do you do? And how was
your weekend?" And then they run out of
ammo. So, I keep these five areas in
life in my back pocket. Five places that
almost always reveals who somebody
actually is. And they all start with
P.
Let's talk about P number one.
With P number one, talk about the past,
their childhood memories, the school
they went to, what they wanted to be
when they were little.
P number two.
This is the patterns that exist in their
life, the habits, the good ones and the
not so good ones, and maybe even their
daily routine. P number three. Their
preferences. What do they love? What
can't they stand? What's the unpopular
opinions that they have?
P number four. This is their pet peeves,
the tiny little things that piss them
off and irritate them way more than they
actually should. P number
>> [snorts]
>> And P number five.
Possibilities. What do they want to try,
learn, or experience one day? And adding
a sixth because I can, ask them about
their preams. Yes, their preams. Some
people do call them dreams, but that's
for pleusers. So, I mean it. What do
they pream about? Ask them. And if you
want to share, maybe you could even
share one of your preams. Don't march
through all six of these questions in
six of these areas like a checklist. You
reach for whichever one fits into the
conversation you're having. Now, these
six areas, they do one job. They move
the conversation from small talk into a
conversation that has way more
substance. Let's resume the example.
Watch what happens. It really gives me a
lot of fulfillment.
>> Yeah, that's great, man. I also believe
in what Vince is doing here, and ever
since I was young, I also really
struggled with my communication. And I
think that's one of the reasons why I
love being here and helping others
improve this skill.
>> Man, that's awesome.
Tell me, what was it like growing up not
being able to communicate properly with
people? Now, the next part of the
framework, T. T stands for track
the echo.
As they answer, you're doing one thing.
You're listening for the echo, which is
what, Vin? An echo is all the other
things that the experience that they
shared could symbolize. Remember the
fishing example right at the beginning
of the video? Fishing isn't just
fishing. It could mean connecting with
nature, solitude, self-sufficiency, so
many things. That's what you're
listening out for here. Can you see how
this makes it easier for you to find
something that you both might have in
common?
So, when you're listening to someone
share about an experience, expand the
way you think about what they're saying.
Think about the emotion behind the
action that they're taking. Think about
the value that they're trying to live
out. Think about the motivation behind
the action. It's not just the experience
itself, because while you don't fish,
you might love nature.
Boom, you've got something in common.
Now, instead of just using the fishing
example, let's go back to the situation
we've been playing out throughout this
entire video between person A and person
B. And if you remember, person B said
that they weren't able to really
communicate well when they were young.
And maybe as person A, they didn't have
trouble communicating. But, what else
would the person who couldn't
communicate when they were younger be
feeling in that experience? They might
have felt lonely, isolated, frustrated,
misunderstood, heck, maybe even
invisible. So, now instead of thinking
to yourself, "Did I struggle to
communicate when I was young?" as being
the only thing that connects you both,
now you're thinking, "Have I felt lonely
before? Have I ever felt isolated? Have
I ever felt frustrated or misunderstood
or maybe even invisible?"
Chances are you have, because in
everything that people say, there's
always layers to what they're saying.
And that's [music] the unlock. Common
ground isn't only, "Oh, that's happened
to me, too." Half the time it's, "Hey, I
felt something exactly the same for a
totally different reason."
The moment you realize that, the number
of people you can connect to now goes
through the roof. Let's resume with the
example. Tell me, what was it like
growing up not being able to communicate
properly with people?
>> Yeah, I felt really confused and
annoyed, and it felt like sometimes I
didn't exist because no one noticed me
and they
couldn't understand me.
I actually really hated primary school.
>> Do you see that? The moment you start to
listen out for the echoes, you'll be
able to find connections with people so
much easier. But, if you're thinking to
yourself, "This sounds great, Vin, but I
still freeze in the moment and I don't
know what to say when I'm with people."
I get it. That's why communication
frameworks like this exist and it's why
they help you structure your thinking
before you speak. So, that when you do
speak, your words aren't jumbled up and
you don't end up rambling. And if you
want to be able to learn the best
frameworks to use when the spotlight is
on you, especially at work, then make
sure you check out my free 2-hour
training. It'll give you more structure
for what to say and how to say it and
how to feel more confident while doing
it. The link is below in the description
or you can scan the QR code. Okay, now
that you've heard the echo, here's what
you do next. You see, which is clarify
the echo.
Here's where you dig another layer
deeper. Once you recognize and hear an
echo, you zoom into it. Most people stop
at the surface level connection. "Oh,
I've been invisible in my life, too."
And then that's it. The magic is in the
detail. So, you ask some clarifying
questions like this. "I actually really
hated primary school."
How did being invisible impact you
through your school years? I mean, what
did you learn from it? How did you break
out of it?
>> You know, I actually moved schools five
times, and at the time it felt like the
worst thing that could have happened to
me.
But, the silver lining was that every
time I went to a new school, I had the
opportunity to reinvent myself. And the
version of me that you see now, I've had
to reinvent nearly five times.
>> Wow. You see what's happening here? You
are well and truly out of Small
Talkville. You're starting to connect on
a deeper level now. And to the final
part of the framework, the H, which
stands for highlight the match out loud
and share your experience like this.
Wow, that's wild. You know, I never
moved schools five times like you did,
but I've actually changed my job three
times in the last five years. And you're
right, sometimes people think a certain
way about you. They have this mold of
who you should be and who they think you
are. And then it's really hard to break
out of it. But, changing jobs and
changing environments for me, like
you've changed schools, it's helped me
have a fresh start each time where
people have no preconceived ideas of who
I was, which allowed me then to step
into a version of me that's sitting
across from you right now. Man, it's
crazy. Been through different things,
but it's similar at the same time. Man,
I never thought about it that way. We
actually have quite a bit in common.
You want some?
>> Yeah, dude. I'd love some. Oh.
Oh, so good. I love pasta.
>> How powerful was that? Match is the
difference between a nice chat and an
actual deep connection. And if you want
to learn more about communication
frameworks like this, make sure you
check out my free 2-hour training that I
mentioned before where I teach you the
frameworks to speak with more clarity,
structure, and confidence in
high-pressure situations. The link is in
the description. I'll see you in the
next one.